good morning Hank it's Tuesday as this
is my last vlog brothers video of the
decade I wanted to share with you some
of my favorite days of the 2010s
although I am leaving out some personal
stuff like the two best days of my
decade and also of my life were the two
days my kids were born but I'm not going
to talk about that here because you have
to draw the privacy line somewhere and
that's where I draw it but other than
that my very favorite day of the decade
was January 15 2013 when you and I
played a sold-out show at Carnegie Hall
while wearing rented tuxedos that
evening have awesome included my
favorite band the mountain goats and
Kimya Dawson and Neil Gaiman and so many
friends and Sara and Katherine and our
parents were all with us and then at the
end of the night I found out my best
friend Chris had flown in to surprise me
and I cried with happiness and the whole
thing was just magical plus Hank I'll
probably never again see you in a tuxedo
so I'm glad I took the opportunity when
it came and the mountain goats played
one of my favorite songs you were cool
which includes the lyrics it's good to
be young but let's not kid ourselves
it's better to pass on through those
years and come out the other side
with our hearts still beating having
stared down demons come back next day
may 30th 2016 the world's favorite
fourth tier English football team AFC
Wimbledon who wear dftba on their shorts
play at Wembley Stadium in a play-off
final for the chance to become the
world's favourite third tier English
football team everything about that day
was perfect from singing with AFC
Wimbledon fans out of pub before the
game to being at Wembley with my dad and
rosianna and my friends Stuart and
Wembley Wombles co-founder Meredith and
then Montserrat II an international
superstar Lisle Taylor scored to put AFC
Wimbledon into the third tier and we
partied all night with fans and friends
and players and my dad and it was just
awesome a best date that wasn't
videotaped December 29th 2016 I'd
reached a point with Turtles all the way
down where I just wasn't sure if it was
ever gonna be a worthwhile or useful
thing and I was staying alone at a small
cabin in Michigan with nothing but a
loaf of bread some peanut butter and an
obscene quantity of diet dr. pepper I'd
been awake all night the night before
and I just couldn't find my way through
to a better ending for the novel and so
finally in desperation I called Sarah
and I was crying and she was like it
sounds like you just need to do a time
jump and then I hung up and wrote the
last 15 pages of turtles all the way
down all in one go and it was roaring
Lee wondrously joyful to finally see a
way through both for ASA
and for me so thank you Sarah okay my
final best day Hank for so long you have
supported my writing like in 2008 when
Paper Towns came out you and Katherine
drove around the country with me in a
rented minivan and played libraries and
bookstores and anyone else who would
have us and you were always there
singing your guts out every time
transforming yourself into a turtle
professor or a sock puppet to make those
readings something more than readings to
turn them into events that would matter
to people and then on September 25th
2018 your brilliant first novel an
absolutely remarkable thing was
published and I finally got to support
you a little bit at the launch event at
Town Hall in New York City to see you
surrounded by copies of your book was
one of the great joys of my life so I
hope you share some of your best
memories of the decade
in the comments section below I kind of
need that positivity and I feel like the
rest of the world might too but for me
while those are some of the days that
stand out a lot of my favorite moments
in the decade were little moments going
to a Joan Mitchell show with Sara
rosianna and I sprawled out across a
lounge at VidCon exhausted and
exhilarated Hank and I eating hamburgers
in the hot Southern California day
seeing the Pettibon spiral for the first
time and being stopped dead by it
my mom showing me her painting of the
lazy boy where I've written all my books
filming crash course with Stan wasting
card space because we couldn't stop
laughing at each other's jokes it's good
to be young but let's not kid ourselves
here's to the next 10 years Hank I'll
see you on Friday